Under the skin is back a conversation
that includes us all.
A conversation where the old ideas,
the old divisions in the old categories
of broken down where we listened to
people on the extremes
trying to achieve a quality with the
Annihilation of category is not
successful.
That's that.
That's exactly right where we hear
voices that have not been heard about
clean and cook.
Without Alabama,
you don't get trump.
We were being coast.
We've been lubricated with where we
invite outsiders into the conversation
where we get thinkers,
orators philosophers from the left and
the right to collaborate or consensual
before reality is we can a new worlds
from the ashes of the old.
Don't want to miss this.
It's going to make you out to survive.
The apocalypse is coming.
We know that the time for pe tribalism
is,
oh,
we have to find a new amalgamation
Kendra from our consciousness and new
algorithm of peace and harmony,
we must find among us a way to confront
the great titans of tech,
the silicon valley giants,
that political rogues,
the great monsters of the cyber world
and the corporate dragons or must be
slain.
We have to find a David to fight this
goliath.
Somehow we must load a single shot and
we can only find it collaboratively and
together and it will not be found on
[inaudible]
the surface.
It will only be found under the skin.